hey guys it's Pete peppers here and I
was going to make a little how-to video
for paradise Bay if you haven't played
it yet it's a resource management game
from King and it's gone through it's
been out for a while now and it's gone
through a couple updates so I think it's
it's it's a cotton pretty cool um I'm
not yeah I don't usually do I don't
usually play these kinds of games but I
think it's a pretty solid release all
the way around and I know some of my
friends have actually really gotten into
it and they play this a lot more than
they play the puzzle games even anymore
so I just wanted to make a just a
introductory and just since I've been
since I have played it this isn't my
real island this is what I just made a
new one that's early on and you know
there's a it takes a while to you know
start to get it leveled up and get
everything going so I figured out some
tips along the way and I figured I would
share so when you're in these early
levels everything's pretty much just you
just follow along with the storyline and
you're going to want to be you know
knocking out all these trade requests
that you get as soon as you can so you
know you're you need to produce as much
as you can one thing that's hard to come
by in the beginning is the coins and the
once you get them there's like some
different things you could do so you
know the the very first thing you want
to do is like you said you'll follow the
storyline but you're going to want to
you're going to want to open up the dock
here where you trade this is the
Wesley's exports you're going to want to
open that up right away because you can
start selling stuff that you have left
over and then you're going to want to
open up this next once you get to level
10 and it's relatively cheap but it's
going to take about
I think 24 hours before you can actually
start having boats come in but once you
do that that's where you're going to get
a lot of your oh it takes five hours
that's not so bad that's where you start
to get your collection items and things
so what I've been doing up to this point
as I've been following along just doing
the simple things and in order to get
extra coins you can see I have about
nine hundred and twelve I'll I'll catch
a lot of shrimp I'll increase the price
to the max price and then I'll go ahead
and sell those and I think for the time
that it takes to to fish those in the
beginning message that's your best bet
I'm going to pause this in a bit and
level up some more before I continue the
video because the next the next major
thing you're going to want to do is to
start expanding your islands and you
can't do that yet so make sure you pick
up that you see I'm picking up the the
chests that are on the board but here's
here's a common kind of thing in the
beginning that you might not know about
like here I could buy this piece of land
I could clear it out for 300 or the
other option and the one I think is
better is to spend that on these coconut
trees they're 250 apiece and you can
have three at any given time and these
are going to be more productive in the
long term like we don't really need the
space right now so most of the time you
don't even really need to do that you
don't even really want to expand that
unless you have a reason to instead like
I said I'm just going to keep throwing
shrimp on and I'm going to complete
those I'm going to build every building
I get a chance to build you can see that
I have the coffee shop under
construction right now and I can get
another turtle but I don't have enough
coin so I would even say that getting
another turtle would be better than you
know opening up more land and you know
you'll see these creditors running
around you're going to collect those at
all times when you see them sometimes
they're on the ground
they're out in the water later on you'll
see you'll find them a lot of times
behind here so you want to look all
around while you're waiting for your
stuff to get done and you can also find
them up here in this this and then you
can also you know visit your friends and
and you can collect them on there too so
I'm going to pause this and pick it up
after I level some more I'm going to
complete some more of these trades I'm
going to sell some more as you can see
these shrimp already but I put in here a
minute ago
already sold so I'm going to collect
that and that will get me closer to
being able to buy that next turtle so
see you in a second
alright guys so I I'm a little bit
further now not a whole lot further but
I did advance some and I'm at another
point where I have some choices to make
and so I just leveled up to level 12 and
I have as you can see now I have more
things I can buy and this is why I was
saying you don't want to waste coins on
other things I have a mole a turtle
those are both 1,500 and I have another
my second wood chops there which would
be a workshop I should say is there
which would be nice but then I had the
blacksmith so I have 1,500 to spend and
I'm gonna um you can see I'm still doing
the shrimp so that I can get more so
definitely the blacksmith is the next
step and there's a couple reasons why
one like I had said earlier that it you
know the production is where you make
more Goods that you can trade and sell
and complete your trade posts later and
that's a big thing to keep in mind
always and as you go they're going to
it's going to take longer for them to
build as you can see they're getting a
little bit longer I think the coffee
shop was an hour and a half and now this
is is five hours and so on and so forth
until they become 24 hours each so you
know you're going to want to have you're
going to
get those down as soon as you can so you
can start to make more coins and
whenever whenever I'm doing this other
stuff I'm making sure that I hit the
rush buttons when I'm when I have a
chance because that cuts 30 seconds off
of that I'm cycling on my crop so that I
can keep a full stock as soon as they
are ready and so you know the basic part
at this point in the game is we want to
be able to make as much production as we
can so that we can have coins we're
going to sell we're going to keep doing
shrimp so that we can sell those right
away and I'll show you one thing here
like I said make sure you jack up the
price to the highest and that'll give us
145 and so you know one of the things
I'll show you here is like the the
shrimp it takes a minute and a half well
it takes two minutes to build a net or
if you're watching you can you can
advance it at a minute and a half and it
takes five to catch a shrimp so one
shrimp at max is 29 on the other hand
you have stuff like iron ore that seems
like it's it's a more valuable resource
because it takes more work to make it it
takes more ingredients and it takes
longer but you can see there's only a
small difference right so the I feel
like as far as everything and same thing
with this this will take like 10 minutes
and the most we can get forward is 20 so
really the most valuable thing you have
is your shrimp in the beginning and that
will change a little bit over time we'll
talk about that later the other part
here is is that you see there's a lot of
with different directions you're going
to want to expand later like over here
this is where your seal house is going
to be and I'll show you all this online
on my on my real Island and we have over
here's the where we can buy things from
other players we can also still visit
other players and buy things that way
but
that's what we'll start to advance it so
the decision you're going to make are
going to be like well we want this this
dock obviously because boats come in and
you can get a lot of XP to level up and
a lot of coins that way and then you can
expand that out so the tough decisions
that you make when you're you're playing
and are like you know do I buy another
dock or do I you know want to do this so
we'll just talk about the different ways
that you HOT you know they can do it but
I think the basic general idea here is
that production is key and production is
going to be how you're going to make
more coins and get more XPS and then
you're also going to like I said want to
you're also going to want to expand your
storage as fast as you can and that's
going to come from the boat trades and
things like that so I'm going to pause
it again
and I'll hit I'm going to I'll give us
two more little sections here one on
when we get to the islands and then the
other one I'll show you my new like my
complete one and show you the different
things that's wow they look when they're
unlocked so I'll be back in a sec
alright so it's a little bit of a few
hours later and now you can see that I I
got all the buildings I have one in
process I can buy another what workshop
which I'll do soon but the one thing I
want to do here is I want to with the
you know 2400 that I have I'm going to
upgrade the next dock you can see I
would both I just traded three to these
to the last boat three pearl so I don't
have any more yet so that's one of the
reasons why having more docks will be
good and this one will be done by the
time I wake up tomorrow
and I can also go ahead and expand this
way now because out here out here we
have the where you can trade with other
islands and real quick you can see like
if I look the next building I'm going to
get is until level 18 so it's fine to go
ahead and go out that way and get
started on this so see now we can open
up the world market and that just helps
as you can buy things when you need them
so I'll get that started before I go to
sleep too and the next thing we're going
to do will be when we get to level 16
we'll be able to go up here and open up
this map little that opens the world map
well level 17 I guess but that's um
that's that's pretty much it for the
beginning part of the game I'll make one
more short clip one whenever I get to
the world map and talk about that from
this point I'm just going to keep
producing as much stuff as I can make as
many coins as I can and get to our point
where we can open up more docks and we
can go to the islands because that's
where we can start to really bring in
coins we can buy stuff cheap there and
sell it for more in our market and I did
buy one of these I was up to I guess
about a hundred and ten in the gems so
when I was selling stuff earlier I
opened one and I would open these with
the the first gems you get can be a
little bit confusing when you first play
because you know it's they're not like
gold bars
they work the same way though the ones
you buy or whatever in other games but
what's kind of nice about these are is
you keep getting them throughout the
game and so you can spend them you just
want to spend them on the right things
and I think opening this up will be able
to bring in more coins and XPS that way
so I would send them on that and then
later whenever you start to have other
things you'll start adding them so that
you can put more crafts in at the same
time when you go away for a while
alright so we'll pick up whenever in a
few more levels and finish off the video
alright so I wanted to end this all with
one last clip but I'm going to have to
make two so I'm gonna make this one kind
of short but here's the situation I have
all my buildings I have opened up the
where you can trade and I now have 5,000
coins so you'd have the choice I have is
to come over this way and go towards the
bazaar or I can open up the next dock
and this is what I'm going to do and the
reason why is because you can see right
now I'm stuck with the two boats I have
and this will happen a lot because you
can't send the boats way like you can
with the with the trade posts you know
if you get a trade post that you don't
want to do you can just hit the garbage
can and you should do this because it'll
pop up with things that you can't really
make at that time but with the boats you
can't so I'm going to invest the 5,000 I
have or the you know 3,000 to 5,000 I
have now to get the next dock going now
that's going to take 12 hours so that's
another reason to get it done now and
the other reason is is because this is
where I want to come next the bazaar is
important and we're going to want to get
it but I wanted I want to get as much
production and coins coming in as I can
and I can do that better by going up
here which I'll show you in the next
video when I get to the next level so
you know just plugging along still doing
the trade post closing them out whenever
I can't get them selling you know
producing stuff and
and stop to sell it in the market over
here and was Lee's exports and just
collecting coins and leveling up so one
more one more installment coming so
we're at level seventeen now and this is
the part I was telling you that the way
I would prefer to go saved up five
thousand dollars and coins and now we
can repair the map table
it's nice you got fifteen hundred of
those coins back and tomorrow I'll
finish this up and show you how that
works and it'll be good to go so you can
see everything is caught up I got two
thousand coins I can save up a little
bit more and then go towards the bazaar
and I'll just keep doing what I have
been doing and level up in the process
so here we are this is the last kind of
early phase of development we have our
in that time we have our three docks
open the next ones thirty thousand so
that will take a really long time to
save up for and now our map table is
done everything else has been the same
we just want to keep you know getting
our new buildings we've got a soup pot
now we want to keep producing we want to
keep doing trade posts and boat trades
so that we can get coins get ex peas you
can see that even though we spent some
gems earlier we have we're back up to
129 so like I said you get a pretty good
amount of those in so that you're going
to spend so don't worry too much about
that spending them spending them for the
right things like expanding your slots
and your exports and adding more adding
more slots in your mill so you can get
more stuff done when you're away from
the game are the best investments as
long as you're only spending on stuff
like that when you need it you'll never
really run out
all right so let's have a look at the
map
so now we have we have extra islands
okay and first ones anglers island so
let's check it out it's automatically
unlocked and well it's actually got one
during one map piece I bought a couple
of these and I got a couple from me from
the world market that's one of the
things that wasn't a production item
that I bought with my coins and the
reason is because this is where you get
more coins so he has for all the
different board there we go they're
going to sell you something for really
cheap and they're going to buy something
as well and it starts out slow isn't
younger term right but once you get the
relationship level up to five you start
getting these and you can get them every
every I think it's every eight hours so
you can out you can you know start to
get a surplus of these kinds of things
and you can sell them so we got four
fish for 28 and sell those for nine you
can see we have a timer here so we'll
come back in an hour
and we'll be able to buy more
they also get animals here so when we
get to the 10th level you can take this
home with us and animals come into play
later so let's look at the rest of the
map over here
so we've out for 428 fish so I can go
right to the market if you want the
exports you can see we got 28 each so
you quadruple our money so obviously
that's a way to make coins and it gets
this kind of exponential get more
valuable things with the more islands
that you unlock and stuff so this is the
Isle of the giving 3 this gives you gem
so it'll give you gems to regular nice
we need four more map fragments for that
one
chameleon Cove it would probably be the
next one that you get you need four more
in the map right mix and you get like I
said you can buy these pretty regularly
people sell them because they get them
out Islands maxed out so it's not so bad
and you can see that the blue maps are
the rare one so there are that and you
see what's no lock you have to get three
levels 24 and 28 so you want to collect
mac map fragments as you go along you
want to open those up as fast as you can
because that's really where you'll start
to get things and you can sort of see it
and hear with what people are selling
who are at higher levels than we are
I guess they kind of keep people that
are around the same amount of year so a
couple other things if you want to if
you don't have a lot what one of the
things that you're going to want to do
is have friends who play the game there
they on their support site on their
forum they have a place where you can
find friends it's a little bit different
if you play on Google Play or if you
play on the on that from the App Store
for Apple so you just want to check
check around and find friends like
there's only three down here now you can
have this maxed out to a lot and that'll
improve your chances of being able to
collect karma and other things that
you're going to need later will open up
after you get the map table our next
thing will be will open the Bazaar we
can make recipes there and start working
on getting our animals and then the seal
house is another way where you can once
you get it opened up you can start doing
dives and dive on your friends dives and
get things in materials and gold a lot
faster so this is my personal Island
that I worked on I played it really I
played it a whole lot in the very
beginning and then I go back and forth
they just had an event so I played it
some more I'm at level 43 there's 50 of
them and I take an approach of just
having production I don't really
decorate my Island I have you know I
have everything kind of where I can
harvest it and just produce coins and
get things really fast
I have everything opened up the once you
do once you do the mat you get you know
I move my mouth table once you move that
to get your Islands you have your bazaar
open and your seal house down here
you'll want to cook you'll want to go
straight up here on the side to where
Clara
is she'll bring more she'll bring more
is in a way of the storyline and you'll
need to you know open up this cave and
she'll come out she's another character
in this story see I have animals here
animals we can we can feed them and they
give us things you get those over in the
bazaar you have to
whenever you're collecting sapphires
Jade and rubies and you can buy these
flowers that's what's nice about this is
that actually takes them out of your it
takes them out of your storage and it
puts it overheating on that so that will
help you have room because storage is a
problem all the way through the whole
the whole process and and just real
quick I'll show you the the map opened
up this is the last island show go they
you know here you you can buy two of
these for twenty to fifty and they sell
for sixteen so every time you buy and
sell these you know I have everything a
button everything and I have two hundred
thousand gold so eventually you know
once you start to really get into it and
some things you will have coin reserve
there's a lot I didn't I didn't open up
all the island parts you know that I
could open any of these now with these
but I just don't really care to decorate
I'll show you some other ones real quick
some people got really into you know
decorating island so they open
everything all the way up let's see yeah
you can see this is much nicer than mine
and they have way more like there's more
animals more decoration and all the all
the they don't have it they have cleared
all the spots out now so it's up to you
I I just don't think people come and
visit that much in it so I don't really
see what the point of spending a lot of
time is but you know teach the zone
however you want to run your island it's
your island so I'm just going to just to
recap really quickly to get to that
point where you have all this stuff
you're going to need gold coins you're
going to need to build all of your
buildings to produce things so that you
can trade with the boats and you can
trade at the trays those that's going to
be your top priority you can see that I
have all my slots opened up till 4:00 on
most and I still have 500 gems so you
know as long as you don't spend them on
random things very often you'll you'll
be able to have plenty of those so you
were going to have you're going to have
production you're going to trade
actively get these open up and just
constantly be trading go to your Islands
from your from your map buy stuff and
sell it to get your coins up make sure
you visit the giving tree' and get your
free gems each day once you do it will
tell you when you know I cut you get
them every 16 hours so you have a little
thing here so that's basically that's
the basic stuff that's all the hard
decisions as far as the beginning goes
I'm going to write up a how to let this
to and I'll put the link in and
description at the bottom so that you
can follow it along but okay so it's a
fun game especially if you like if you
like resource management
you know or you play farmville back in
the day or one of those you know one of
the ones that's popular now you'll
probably like it they vet like they've
done a pretty good job of at adding new
things they just had the the event the
trade fest event which was cool so it's
social also you know you got your
friends I recommend getting active in
the support forum and looking for group
on Facebook there's a couple good ones I
don't have one for this game because you
know it's not the same as my other
groups so but yeah you could find people
who play and you can trade and when you
need something you can trade or
something that you have and I don't know
give it a like if you have any questions
leave them in the comments I might make
one another one down the road about some
more advanced things but this is pretty
much all you need to know so Pete
peppers thanks for watching